νακάνου την πόλι που ανάλαβα ό αν αντελειώχε θυτία μου πέντε βήματα πος τα μπροστά
είνα την πάρω πενερίνα προ τά προστά να κάμο πένται πράγματα τα οποία ναείναι αποδεκτών
ότιείναι καλύτερα από αυτά από ανάλαβε πρόσφυγας από την αμόχωστο που βρέθηκε στη λάρναρα καταγωγμεν
από τη βατιλήν αμοχώ του γεννήθηκα και μεγάλο α στη λάρνα κάνε το χί για
νια πόοι πμετο οκτός τον προσφυθικών εκισμόν ταναγον αναργύρουν και ο προλέω πάν τοτε έχουμεδύο
αγαπεση μια είναι η καταγωγή μας το χωριό των γνονιο μας τοτων προγόνομ μας αλλά
και από την άλλην πόλη η οποία γεννηθήκαμε μεγαλώσαμε μεγαλών ενοικογένι μας και όπως λέω
εμεί δη προσφηκες είμαστε εντιπλά υποχρί στη λεοικα προεκτρός από το γεγόνός ότι ίναι υπόλι
που γενηθήκαμε και μεγαλώσαμε και οφίλουμε να την κάνουμε καλύτερη είναι και υ πόλι ου
υποδεκτηκε του ιδικούς μας σε μια τις κολι στιχουμε είναι ου πόλι πόδο και στις
ιοείναι ένμα μια δεύταρ είν ευκαιρία χαραεμίς είμαστε διπλά υποχρείή ως αυτή την πολή χωρίς
πολύ σκέψει πιο είναι το μεγαλύτερο πρόβλημοα από ααντιμετωπίζι σήμερα ηλάρνακα τάξει το μεγαλύτερο πρόβλημα
δεν μπορώ να πό ότι είναι ένα ξεκάθαρον είναι μια σειρά που προκλήσεις τις οποίες
πρέπει να αντίμε το πίσε ένας δημαρχώσ ένας δημαρχος είνα πεύθουμε από τα πιο μικρά
μεχρει τα πιουμεγάλα στη σε μια πολύ καιαντιλαβάνεκαι ότι μπορείνα μην δίνουμε πολύ στημουμασία στα
μικρά αλλά κάποιες φορεςε είνι αυτά πό πηρειάζουε την πιοριτα ζωής του δημότι δηλαδή από
τν καθαρικό ότηα από το πράσινο από τους δρόμους από τα πισβοτρόμια πάμε στα μεγάλα
και ξεχάννουμε τα μικρά αλλά σε έναν πολύ μεγάλο βαθμόν ένας πολύ σα είνα κανο
πιμεένος από τα μικρά εξακτάτε συντα μεγάλα τα οποία έχουμε μια υποχρέωσι νααφέρουμε περισότερη οικονο
μια ναψυξη στη λά να κάνα αυψήσουμε τις δουλιές να να δώσουμε μια πρόκτηγής τους
νέου τις πολύς άρα θεωρώ ότι ένας πωστώσι δήμορχοσει δεν ασχολείτει μόνο μένα πράγυμα να
σχολίτοιμε όλα αυτά έτσι ώστε να είναισε ένα βαθμόν επιτυχημένος δημαρχος παλια άκουγέ αποτοπικούς φορίς
και όχιμόν από τους καλιώτες ότι λάρνακα είναι ουτός